[Musica]
limate
nel cielo la terra lontana
nato
no arriva
[Musica]
ok sto iniziando ad abituarmi ma da dove
dovrò iniziare non vedo nessuno qui si
vede che la creatura sia già scappata
no no non ci sono né buchi nei passaggi
deve essere ancora qui magari è così
piccola che non la riesco a vedere sarà
meglio chiamare gli altri ma ma come
funziona misto roso anita sito di eco
ora funziona titolo io che succede se è
arrivata tutta intera
sì io sto bene ma non vedo nessuno qui
credo che la creatura si è già scappata
anche se non vedo nessun passaggio
aperto non è possibile
queste gabbie hanno un vetro speciale
nessuno può scappare da lì anita in
queste celle è rappresentato alla
perfezione l'habitat delle creature
magiche
dimmi un po che cosa vedi è davvero
grande questa gabbia
ci sono degli alberi giganteschi di
solito nelle gabbie grandi ci stanno
creature grandi beh questo non è una
bella notizia
comunque vedo un grande albero con le
foglie rosa e
ci sono delle piume delle piume
argentate che cosa non sarà mica si è
mancato poco
aiutatevi non può che fare bene risponde
[Musica]
buono aiuto ma delle ali un becco enormi
maledizione doveva smettere di
funzionare proprio ora posso fare
e adesso o no
eccolo di nuovo ma che succede
[Musica]
adesso calmati amica mia
sono qui per aiutarti come dici non ti
fidi più di nessuno perché cosa ti è
successo
ti hanno rinchiusa qui lontano dai tuoi
polsini mi dispiace tanto amica mia
ora ci sono io qui lascia fare a me
[Musica]
adesso sei libera torna dei tuoi piccoli
ti staranno aspettando vivai e stato
bellissimo conoscerti buon viaggio amica
mia
e non credo ai miei occhi ai già
raggiunto la forma leggendaria del tuo
potere incredibile
durante la tua prima missione dalla
prima volta che ti ho vista sapevo che
inter c'era qualcosa di speciale e oggi
ne ho avuto la conferma
sei stata bravissima anita dico sul
serio
grazie vitale e grazie viaggiatori
stellari è stato tutto merito vostro
avete creduto in me sin dall'inizio
[Musica]
ragazze arriva qualcuno
non ci prenderanno mai presto nel
portale congratulazione per l'ammissione
viaggiatore e attenta per avermi
insegnato fanno leggendaria nel suo
potere bene city pronti per le prossime
venture
[Musica]
finalmente un po di tranquillità
beh direi che ce la meritiamo visto
tutti i servi oscuri che abbiamo mandato
a casa con la coda tra le gambe
anita tu che sei brava con la matematica
quanti erano erano 21 invece genito
della matematica
questa volta ti sbagli ne abbiamo
sconfitto menti
[Musica]
ma a dire il vero io con i numeri non mi
sbaglio mai ma a 20 21 che differenza fa
tanto
di cuccioli non si sono ancora accorti
di me mi basterà aspettare che operano
al portale della nostra detesto il
freddo ragazzi voglio tornare su astral
adesso hai ragione si è fatto tardi
vitale andiamo ok
[Musica]
voi andate pure devo parlare un attimo
con anita dimmi vitale c'è qualcosa che
non va
no no anzi volevo dire che sei stata
davvero brava oggi grazie davvero
beh in realtà anch'io devo dirti
qualcosa sì dimmi pura
ecco volevo dirti che tu mi piaci
mi piace tanto
[Musica]